earlier this week three Russian
journalists were murdered while
investigating a private Russian security
company in the Central African Republic
a country in Africa for those who aren't
familiar
Kiril radtchenko alexander restorer gwee
EV and oricon jamal were all laid to
rest in Moscow earlier this week they
were going to spend two weeks in the
Central African Republic they were
investigating a Russian security company
named the Wagner group which has
interests in diamond and gold and
uranium mines in ciear and it's also
considered Putin's private army the
leader of Wagner is currently under US
sanctions for aiding russia-backed
rebels in Ukraine not surprising given
everything we know about the intertwined
nature of Russian Oleg Oleg arts and in
February the Wagner group was also
involved in a four-hour attack against
American commando stationed inside of
Syria now if you know anything about
Putin and we know some things about
Putin you know that investigating
anything that's nicknamed Putin's army
is probably gonna be a little bit
dangerous for you and it was for these
three journalists because they were
ambushed their driver somehow survived
that's part of the question around
exactly what went down the driver said
they were ambushed by ten men who spoke
Arabic and were wearing turbans as the
story goes and again the driver got away
completely unharmed which is question
number one about what exactly went on
here and as you research the story you
find out that the organization funding
these journalists was the investigations
management Center which is bankrolled by
an anti-putin Russian oligarch or in
other words the paychecks for these
journalists came from someone who is
anti Putin in Russia the journalists
were on their way to meet with someone
who had promised to provide access to
officials who could speak on the record
about Russian involvement in the Central
African Republic and of course they
never made it to that meeting and these
deaths immediately become suspicious
they become appended to this very long
and growing list of suspicious deaths
among Russian dissidents and opposition
journalists and of course the Putin
defenders are saying listen guys Central
African Republic is dangerous for all we
know the driver sold them out since
after all the driver did survive there's
nothing to see here at all except that
we have of course example after example
after example of Wagner related quote
accidents that happened to Russians
there's one example from April a Russian
journalist who was investigating Wagner
in Syria fell out of his fifth floor
apartment not the most common accident
that people have at home not exactly
stubbing your toe with that coffee table
and then of course we could do an hour
just unsuspicious dissident and
journalist deaths related to russia but
on wednesday the US issued sanctions
against russia for that chemical weapon
used to kill former russian agent sergey
skripnikov occurred extensively so I've
said it before I've said it many times
to figure out a story you sometimes have
to look at the micro and you sometimes
have to look at the macro oftentimes
what conspiracy theorists do to trick
people into believing their conspiracy
or to distort stories is they will focus
on the wrong one on a story where you
should be focusing on the micro they
will focus on the macro or vice versa we
can never be 100% sure that these three
journalists died for their anti Putin
work or because they were maybe
suspected of already having something on
Vladimir Putin that's another
possibility but it fits into the broader
pattern of these deaths right you have a
bunch of cases where people who are
hostile to the Putin regime they're
investigating the Putin government
they're doing this type of work they die
in unusual circumstances poisonings
vehicle ambushes in foreign countries
falling out of high windows accidentally
stabbing themselves 10 times in the back
maybe that last one I made up but it's
sort of the prototype of these
situations so yeah the Central African
Republic is dangerous for anyone who is
not from
and even for people who are from there
anyone could fall out of a window all of
that stuff is possible but here it's the
pattern that's difficult to justify as a
coincidence and as far as the ciear is a
dangerous and remote place it has
nothing to do with Putin well listen if
they're willing to poison someone on
British soil why wouldn't they be
willing to do something even more
noticeable like a car ambush in the
Central African Republic and this is the
authoritarianism
that Trump is impressed with time and
again when it's Duterte from the
Philippines when it's Putin when it's
air Dewan when it's Jing ping whoever
Trump is impressed with these types of
authoritarian tendencies these are the
guys Trump really likes and it is yet
another not one but three Russian
journalists doing work hostile to Putin
maybe already had stuff on Putin who end
up in an unfortunate wrong place wrong
time situation I guess that's what it's
being called if you believe that if you
believe that send me your thoughts this
is something already being discussed on
the David Pakman show
subreddit at david pakman.com slash re d
di t we will take a break we have a
great interview coming up next more
stories the bonus show a lot going on
today and I'm glad you're with us
today's program was made possible in
part by Blink esteem / Pakman I love
bling cast it's the really perfect app
for anybody who likes politics and
learning and if you're watching or
listening to the David Pakman show I'm
sure you love politics and learning and
what blinka says is take the best and
most popular non-fiction books they
condense them into 15-minute audiobooks
that you can listen to in one sitting
and you can learn about politics
philosophy psychology economics often we
don't have the time to actually read as
many books as we would like I know that
I'm at my limit for how much I can read
and this way you can absorb the most
important valuable information from
books in just 15 minutes maybe on your
way to work maybe on your way to the gym
maybe cooking vegan recipes at home
whatever is your thing and our audience
can get a seven day free trial by going
to blink accom slash
Pakman if you're watching on YouTube
I've put a link in the video description
and after the free trial if you like it
and I think you will
you can continue enjoying thousands of
condensed audiobooks for just about 5
bucks a month you can go to be li NK is
t-dot-com
slash PA k ma n to sign up